oh okay good
she just was lying on the ground when
they were having a chat it was great
yeah they're the best for kids it was
absolutely the best for kids all right
let's uh
no they're very quick I'm glad I don't
know
yeah
these kinds of support exactly it's the
most important
um you know Patron when I met Patron
I've got the T-shirt
great well nice to meet him nice to see
you all it's really a privilege and a
pleasure to welcome my friend Vladimir
back to the UK the conflict is a pivotal
moment Ukraine is Bravely defending
itself against Russian aggression but at
this moment it's been really good for us
to have the time to talk together in
private about the support that the UK is
giving and how we can make sure that
that support is not just here for today
but into the future as well to ensure
that Ukraine and its people Triumph not
just on the battlefield militarily but
also stand up for those values of
Freedom democracy and the rule of law
that we all hold very dear we've had
some very good conversations and
Vladimir it's great to have you here
thank you very much first of all for me
and for our team is privilege the new
host us here today Rishi and thank you
especially especially you and your
government for supporting us really at
this moment like you said at the moment
of challenges the moment for us for our
society our people especially for our
soldiers moment is
tough difficult but anyway
we need success and I'm happy that in
this way we are in way of preparing very
important contravensive steps you are
with us together with us
all Great Britain you and your
government as it's very important so
thank you very much for all support of
course with uh with you know all this
best attitude to our people from your
people but of course we concentrate on
on Military Support and thank you very
much for this package that you prepared
great huge really what can save the
lives for a lot of people thank you so
much
right we'll take some questions yes Mr
President uh you made it very clear you
need more advanced weapons more quickly
is it fair to say that you cannot begin
your new counter-offensive until you get
them and prime minister today the crown
in Spaceman Dimitri peskov has warned
that Russia views the new UK military
package extremely negatively does that
worry you
yes
um thank you very much for your question
we really need some some more time not
too much we'll be ready you know in some
time I I want to be very honest with you
I I can't share with you some days I I
just don't want to prepare not not for
our friends there are no secrets from
our friends but there are some secrets
from from our neighbors that that's why
we have to to prepare and and I'm here
not only because of this support but of
course including this support it will
help us to be more strong but also to
thank you to to your people to to
government it's very very important now
when some countries not all of you know
of the world world but some countries
are near with us from first days of
full-scale war and I'm thankful That's
Great Britain is one of these countries
I look it's interesting to hear from the
Kremlin what I'd say is you know Russia
is conducted an unprovoked and illegal
attack on the Ukrainian people it is
carrying out horrific war crimes and
something vladder and I have been
speaking about uh just awful treatment
of its citizens and as we said right at
the beginning the UK will remain
steadfast in supporting Ukraine and its
people to defend itself against that
aggression When Vladimir was last here
some months ago I talked then about the
provision of long-range weapons because
of the capability that they would offer
I'm pleased with the first country to be
able to do that and I'm pleased that
they will make a difference to the
defense of Ukraine and we will keep
providing support as you've seen today
with long-range offensive drones for
example more anti-aircraft and there
will be further support to come and
that's what we've been talking about
today but I think it's important for the
Kremlin to also know that we're not
going away
right we are here for the long term we
remain steadfast in wanting to defend
Ukraine not just now to reclaim its
rightful territory but also to ensure
that Ukraine has a means to defend
itself into the future as well and
that's another topic of conversation
that we've had today is about the
security Arrangements that we should put
in place amongst Allied countries for
Ukraine for the long term to ensure that
it can defend itself and provide
effective deterrence against future
Russian aggression
uh president zielinski when you were
last in the UK you made a plea for
Western fighter jets
um how are negotiations going and prime
minister where does the UK stand on that
answer thank you very much today we
spoke about the Jets very important
topic for us because we can't control
the sky you know it so I think you know
everything deeply because we're real
Partners you really knows all the
details what's going on on our
Battlefield thank you very much and uh
we want to create these uh Jets
Coalition and I'm very positive with it
we spoke about it and I see that in the
closest time you will hear some I think
were important decisions but we have we
have to work a little bit more on it
yes look we we are going to be a key
part of the Coalition of countries that
provides that support to Vladimir and
Ukraine now it is not a straightforward
thing as vladder and I have been
discussing to make build up that fighter
combat aircraft capability it's not just
a provision of planes it's also the
training of pilots and all the logistics
that go alongside that maybe UK can play
a big part of that one thing we will be
doing starting actually relatively soon
is uh training of Ukrainian pilots and
that's something that we've discussed
today we're ready to implement those
plans in in relatively short order which
will mean that we're training Ukrainian
citizens to become absolutely combat
ready aircraft pilots and particularly
whether it comes to Nato tactics as well
because that's an important part of the
long-term relationship between our
countries so we've had very good
productive discussions on that today
other countries are involved I'm talking
to those leaders I'll be doing more of
that this week in my International
engagement and we're very keen to build
that coalition of countries to give
Vladimir and his people the aircraft
support that they need
I question the president uh
foreign
fantastic all right thank you very much
everybody thank you very much thank you
dude
[Music]
thank you
foreign
what's up
I'll tell you if the helicopter
thank you
foreign